foreign
[Music]
so I want to share with you the story of
evolution
as you can see this Evolution
unsurprisingly starts at sea
see this is me and I just started out my
master's degree in Marine ecology
and I went out to the Red Sea to do some
fish sampling and when I was there I was
completely overwhelmed by the beauty of
the coral reef with all these beautiful
shapes colors and really nice looking
fish but when I was done sampling and
looking at all these crazy fish and it
was time for me to go in and fill in the
data I was welcomed by this
ugly unintuitive hard to navigate
Microsoft Access forms and this is the
starting point for our journey
this journey is a walkthrough of how I
moved from using Microsoft Access
to using Google Sheets
and using R to do our own lab
custom-made database
and I hope that whether you're using
Microsoft Access now or Google Sheets or
any of these different alternatives for
making data forms
you will find some lessons that I've
learned something that you could use in
your workflow
so the first step in this walkthrough
was to understand our needs
and to understand our needs I just have
to say a few words about how exactly we
operate so we are as I said a marine
ecology lab
and we are going using scuba diving to
do some underwater surveys so we go out
there as you can see here with
um water resistant piece of paper and a
pencil and we just do some records of
the fish species and they're abundant
when we are underwater
so why do we need
micros why did we need Microsoft Access
to do that so first we know we needed a
big data set so as you can see from this
photo these are taken several years
apart we are doing this for a long time
and we have no intention of stopping
anytime soon and you can see why
another thing
we need a strict for our database we
need a strict form of data validation
because this fella
their name is Paul mccantus imperato and
if you don't try that exactly as the
bottom row you're going to have a lot of
problems down the road and that's true
for any of the cells that we have in our
data form
most importantly we need relational data
so our data is structured in a
relational format where we have the trip
the topmost level is mainly the location
where we are diving in the world and the
date then we have the site which is like
more close-up of who is diving where
exactly like in the actual dive site
then we have the transect the underwater
environmental data so that's the
visibility the depth the substrate
lastly we have the observation itself
the species of the fish and its
abundance
when we use Microsoft Access unknowingly
we made some sacrifices
so first we had really bad user
interface
so for us it was really hard to work
with Microsoft Access
I remember clicking the wrong button a
few times getting this really loud error
message it was a help to at least for me
it was a hell to work
another thing that was really
detrimental to our workflow is that we
couldn't figure out how to do
simultaneous data entry for our needs
sorry
so what happened is we had to actually
email the database file from one person
to another and so we took turn filling
in the data so sometimes it could take
more than a week until it was your turn
to do so and it was really detrimental
to the quality of the data
lastly
since we didn't build the database
ourselves it was really hard for us to
make any customization needed for our
needs so for example we are working on
both the Mediterranean Sea and the Red
Sea there are completely differences
with completely different animals we
need different protocols and for this we
need a different database
so that was also a problem
taking into account all of these things
we set out to create our own database
so what we did was we create so that was
our prototype now okay we have this
giant Google spreadsheet for an entire
Expedition and every day we had someone
in charge of manually creating different
spread different worksheets within the
spreadsheet different work different
worksheets for each of the different
surveyors of that day
uh so when I created this Google sheet
product type
I I needed to take some drastic measures
so I won't have any user error okay I
didn't know how to do that so my first
my first idea was to have this really
horrendous color coding and I'm going to
show you we had this bright red trip
data so these are different forms all
the forms are in different colors so we
have this this trip data in red then we
add this uh yellow is it yellow here
this yellow site data
the green transact data and lastly that
blue Observer data so as you can see
really nice colors and
to connect this to connect all of these
The Observers themselves had to copy and
paste IDs so we could create this
relational data
but then so what happens is that for
every Expedition we have this a lot of
different worksheets within a
spreadsheet that as you can see some red
some blue
it's a whole mess but this is where we
used Google Sheets it was Google Sheets
at the time now it's Google sheets4
we could read by that color coding
so and then using that ID that the user
had to copy and paste we could use
diplier to connect it all to a flat
data set that we can work with
now I know it's a mess and if you have
this space if you have this expression
right now then yeah this is the
expression that all my colleagues had
when I presented that idea and I told
them let's stick with it
it it can be worse than what we
currently have
it wasn't worse but the thing is it
doesn't have to be perfect all right so
this is the This Is Us
this is Crete 2019 and I know it doesn't
look like that but we are currently
harder to work filling in the data
um
so as you can see we're doing that
together
so that's an important thing we could we
managed to solve one big problem which
was the simultaneous data entry so now
that we can work online
as you can see here it's the blue one so
one once that we managed to solve this
problem and I know that the Prototype
works it's time for us to adjust to make
the necessary adjustment to make this
data form database much more much better
to work with
so how did we do that
mainly by increasing our dependency of
Google Drive and Google Sheets 4 package
okay so we have a great tool for
actually working with Google Drive and
Google Sheets and we managed to automate
the entire process
so what we did at first
we had an offline file that replaced
that old red yellow and red worksheets
that we had now they're offline
and from this we can set out to automate
the whole thing
and we use Google Drive for the
housekeeping and navigation
and for the manipulation we used Google
Sheets for
more specifically
we had Drive macdier to create
individual folders for every sampling
day so now instead of having one big
Google spreadsheets that's just
somewhere on Drive
we have this Iraq hierarchy when we have
an expedition
directory and within it for each day we
have a different folder so it's much
more
organized
and GS4 create this function we used to
upload that offline file
from which we create the metadata
we use Drive find and drive CP in order
to copy and paste pre-existing templates
that we had
um
to today's folder so then we use sheet
copy and range right in order to
manipulate those
three existing templates plastic to
break up
to manipulate these pre-existing
templates into whatever necessary for
today so changing site numbers hour Etc
lastly well what I really like is that
we have drive share and we use this
function in order to send out specific
email for specific users so they can
only change their own data so they can
only fill out their own forms
and it's really good because they don't
have to mess around with anything in the
database and they can't accidentally
erase or change someone else's data and
for them it's really easy because all
they have to do now is get an email
and they set out sit out and they fill
out the forms
so this is what we get
this is a folder for a day and we have
the metadata up there and as you can see
we have individual spreadsheet for each
of the different Observers
and in order to do that I had to took
some uh to be some
be creative in a way and let's zoom in
into one of the spreadsheets so first
thing as you can see the colors are much
better
uh they're not really bright anymore
and
I wanted to have a great
strong connection between the
environmental data and the fish data
okay so we're doing ecology which is
basically the relationship between
species and its environment so we wanted
to have this demonstrated in our
database in our forms
to do that as you can see columns A and
B
don't follow the same logic as column C
and H
with some people would say he's
unorthodox and correct and for those of
you don't who can't see that
A and B each row does not represent an
observation it is a long format
but once you realize that you can go
from this long format into a wide format
fairly easily using the title verse
then it opens up a whole world of
possibilities for you for example
on another project where we do quadrat
sampling
I managed to take the exact piece of
paper that surveyors go to to the field
and I managed to copy it almost verbatim
into a digital form
making the transition from the actual
survey data from the actual real-wall
data to the Digital Data much more
intuitive for my users
and
I encourage you all to think about how
user oriented your data forms are at the
moment because I know I've been taught
as well that you should make your data
as computer readable as possible for
analysis visualization
Etc
but at the same time all of us were
taught how easy it is to manipulate the
data shape
so we could also tend to benefit from
being having more user-oriented data
so we could then get so we could
minimize the errors from those users
because it will be much more intuitive
for them to fill in the data forms and
have
that will make our data much better at
the end
so this was our project this is how it
went for quite a while this worked quite
well it was really automated and we
worked for two years or so on this type
of farms but as we continue to use this
we realized that we need to make
additional changes because as we kept
using this database
so did our knee and our needs change
so we realized that having an offline
file was creating a bottleneck because
we need to have someone who knows
exactly how to type in the specific
observer's name and and all kinds of
stuff
then we decided to put that on the cloud
as well
and then using the Google Sheets GS4
browse function
we can open up the browser directly from
rstudio
and then it opened up something like
that sorry
and then you just fill in with data
validation you're feeling Who's the who
are The Observers for today so as you
can see uh I took this opportunity to
thank all my colleagues here and my
collaborators whose feedback was really
what drove this thing forward so while I
did the coding and I presented the idea
and everything
their feedback is what drove this thing
forward if it wasn't for them we would
still be stuck in that ugly color phase
honestly so thanks for that another
thing since we built this thing from the
ground up now it's really easy for us to
make adjustments whenever we need
so for example let's say we have another
project now
we just have a template change a few
lines of code not even change we just
add a few lines of code and we now have
a whole new database for another project
really easy to work with
so basically we can do whatever we want
using Google Sheets for NR Studio
and now it's even more automated in a
sense that you just run
one line of code for example you
reselect yeah you select
what kind of projects are you working on
fill in the data like the actual
Observer data and just
here as you can see here also you just
confirm that it's correct and then R
does anything for you everything for you
you can take a few minutes make some
coffee
and then you spend afternoon filling
data with your friends together and
colleagues So This Is Us enjoying
filling data as you can see we really
like our job I hope this convinced you
uh on the power of using R right from
the start of the data manipulation stage
I mean right from We're actually getting
the data
um if you
if you want to explore this option of
having a more custom made database some
things to consider
so the first thing
consider what exactly do you need out of
your database
okay think about whether you are
currently meeting your needs or or are
you simply overkilling your needs or
what you are doing right now
and in order to meet those needs don't
be afraid to be creative right if you
data needs if you need a triangular
shaped pyramid data you can do it okay
don't be afraid to pursue the type of
data that you want
lastly
pay attention to whatever your users
feedback is and make sure to keep moving
forward with whatever project you are
currently working on
and if you want to see how we keep
moving this project forward or you're
interested in the code try to replicate
this for your own needs then you can go
to our GitHub page and I'll make sure to
upload this slide as well to GitHub and
if you have any questions I'm free
willing to help and thank you for
listening
[Applause]
[Music]